Say hello to Android Things 1.0,
It’s Google’s managed operating system.
Used to build and maintain IoT devices on a large scale.
I am Wien Piecass,
Today I will explain the new features in version 1.0.
How does it provide long-term support for production equipment,
And a new system-level module hardware lineup.
So what is Android Things?
Android Things is Google's managed operating system.
Allows you to build and maintain IoT devices on a large scale.
We provide a powerful platform,
Rich developer API with certified hardware
And using the security of the Google backend infrastructure,
Manageable software updates to do heavy work,
So you can focus on building your product.
Version 1.0 is the first version of Android Things.
Available for your production equipment.
We just finished the developer preview.
The preview SDK has been downloaded more than 100,000 times.
Developer feedback and participation
It is critical to our process of moving towards 1.0.
We are very grateful to the 10,000 developers,
They submitted the error,
Participate in the event and post it in our community to provide us with feedback.
The core part of our IoT platform is the supported hardware.
Based on system level modules or SOM design.
So what is this?
SOM is a fully integrated component.
With CPU, memory, Wi-Fi Bluetooth and flash storage,
You can go directly to the final design.
It's like using a library when writing software.
SOM is certified by Google and we have a motherboard support package.
These include the kernel, drivers and libraries for Android support.
With Android Things 1.0, we announce support
Based on NXP, SOM designed by Qualcomm and MediaTek,
These modules have been certified for production.
It can be mass produced to create real consumer products.
If you want to try Android Things right away without buying SOM,
You can even use any kind of development platform,
Even the Raspberry Pi 3,
This highlights an important feature of Android Things.
It can be prototyped quickly and easily.
When you are ready for production,
According to your needs, you can easily purchase small or large quantities of SOM.
Then your software will run.
Then you can design your own printed circuit board or PCB.
Connect your hardware to the SOM.
When building an IoT device,
It is very important to stay safe.
Provide timely software updates over the Air or OTA
Is one of the basic parts,
The production hardware platform supports stability fixes and security patches.
Automatic updates are enabled by default for all devices.
For each Android Things version,
Google will offer three years of free stability fixes and security patches.
Additional extension support options are available.
Even after the official support window ends,
You can still continue to push app updates to your device.
Upload using the Android Things console
Contains updated Android APKs,
So that the OTA mechanism can push them to your device.
You can initially try to use 100 active devices
For non-commercial use.
When you are ready for mass production,
We will provide you with a distribution agreement.
You are now ready to mass sell your equipment to the public.
With Android Things,
You can build apps using the rich framework provided by the Android SDK and Google Play services.
Including today’s mobile developers
Use the same UI toolkit, multimedia support and connection API.
You can also easily transfer your app
Integrate with popular Google services such as Firebase, TensorFlow
And Cloud IT Core.
This is done using many existing Android client libraries.
Since it is Android,
So you can use Android Studio and all its languages ​​and tools directly.
This means you can do it in Kotlin as needed.
Easy programming and debugging in Java, C++ or C.
Who else is using Android Things?
You may have seen it
New voice-activated speakers from Polk, LG and iHome,
And smart displays from Lenovo, LG and JBL.
These devices showcase the power of Google Assistant.
And will be launched soon to the store near you.
There are also many startups and design agencies that use Android Things.
Come and create new ideas for the variety of devices you will soon see.
We want to make it easy for anyone to start building IoT devices.
Without having to own your own factory,
Also does not require a lot of money.
This is part of our efforts to democratize hardware development.
Make it available to more software developers.
If you want to start using Android Things,
We have a great community website
AndroidThings.withgoogle.com,
You can view the developer kit in it
And interesting projects created by others.
What is next?
Get some hardware, view the documentation,
Download some sample source code and try it.
Join our community and ask questions
And share your thoughts with others.
Android Things 1.0 is now open.
And ready to put into production.
I really look forward to seeing
All the exciting products you build.
I am Wien Piecass, looking forward to seeing you next time.